seul
bonsoir chloé bonsoir anthony merci
d'être avec nous
alors on va parler de votre caméra
cachée qui a été incroyable qu'on a fait
avec cyril hanouna elle est juste folle
mais avant ça j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on
fasse connaissance moi je vous connais
déjà mais c'est pour les gens qui nous
regardent vous habitez dans le sud c'est
ça c'est ça mon père y est là où il ya
du soleil et la fête général c'est vrai
que maintenant vous êtes ensemble ça va
faire six ans ok non pas du tout tu mens
7 en
trois sets le 15 septembre alors
racontez moi plutôt votre votre
rencontre comment ça s'est passé avant
sa rencontre et parce qu'il travaillait
dans mon village et qu'on avait une amie
en commun d'accord et mais monsieur
n'avait pas très bonne fin très bonne
réputation pour moi voilà c'est un
charmeur professionnelle et en plus de
saab
j'étais en couple ah oui la petite
difficulté là peut-être attirer aussi
pourquoi est-ce que tu as tu as eu le
déclic de dire bah pourquoi pas ça peut
être mon futur stop
assez sage de suite
passer de lui pas sûr de lui mais
opportuniste et confiant
et de tout ça est né un peu timide and
on and future petite merveille il va
avoir quatre en quatre ans il va bien
tout va bien tout va bien il va très
bien le carter de sa mère
[Musique]
bon c'est vrai il était gentil at on un
petit
patron l'a fâché non plus vous attendez
aussi un petit bébé oui oui qui est en
préparation
le concept ulla trois mois je vais sur
le 4e là au niveau du sexe du bébé est
ce que vous savez c'est une fille ou un
garçon et non on sait pas surprise
surprise durant l'émission il ya une
phrase que vous avez dit que j'ai
beaucoup aimé la vie doit être une fête
car on en a qu'une qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
c'est une phrase qui nous représente
puisqu'on a des gros fêtard
l'année du sud est ça on aime faire la
fête on aime c'est convivial les apéros
le ciment de votre couple la frette
justement l'union c'est bientôt mon sens
tu vas découvrir la caméra cachée plan
tony a fait avec l'aide de cyril c'est
sur l'idée de cyril donc c'est vraiment
du très très haut niveau qu'a vécu ça et
maintenant tu vas voir les images
j'étais un bon moment aussi un peu de
peur un peu voilà beaucoup comme ça j on
est passé des montagnes russes bon alors
attendez on regarde d'abord
[Musique]
regarde avec qui je suis je te présente
anthony
s'allumer belgique
je sais tout sur lui maintenant et sur
sa chérie avec angie
moi je veux un truc tu vois vraiment
spectaculaire je veux que tout le monde
soit au courant que je laime quelque
chose vraiment qui qui fait quoi et des
tumeurs et gars là dessus
exactement
écoute on aime bien dazhou kenji y en a
comme moi voilà l'ambiance quoi
d'ailleurs il a un petit air de kenji je
passe tu voyais d'un faussaire de kenji
ya un truc
[Rires]
j'ai
jeu avec
bon il ya moyen de leur faire une très
belle surprise alors
je te fais confiance bien sûr
merci et bon super ça va lui plaire
merci merci vraiment à +10
bon je pense que chloé est vraiment très
loin de se douter de tout ce qui est en
train de se tramer pour vous écoute je
te cache pas que moi non plus je suis
dans le doute aussi parce que je sais
pas ce qui va ce qui va préparer quoi en
tout cas ça va être grandiose c'est sûr
tu connais sert il mais c'est le but et
je suis vraiment vraiment content et je
me languis vraiment chez un patient on
est très excité on installe nos caméras
cachées dans un taxi qui sera notre
alibi pour la surprise de chloé mais le
voyage ne va pas être aussi 38 lequel le
pense
pendant la fin de la préparation de la
caméra cachée je pars avec anthony
chercher le plus important pour une
demande en mariage la pinte
[Musique]
anthony and a ajouté merci devront
souvent chez vous on est ravi ravi
l'excitation
alors comme tous les hommes oui je sais
pas ce que veut ma femme on va peut être
regardée de leurs plans on a par exemple
que salutaire qui est juste magnifique
l'anneau est entièrement sertie diamant
et vous avez un magnifique diamant
central
de co2 km c'est très épuré a demandé
deux fois
plus à bien c'est joli c'est très beau
certains pensent que ça y est j'ai
flashé c'est vrai ça lui irait comme un
gant c'est magnifique ouais comme ça
laquelle rappelle exactement c'est comme
les femmes on a un coup de foudre se
[Musique]
joignent la soeur d'anthony pas
recherché chloé en taxi pour la surprise
de demandes en mariage david le
chauffeur de taxi est notre complice il
va faire croire qu'il a des dons des
dons de voyance
c'est mon seul
c'est sur mon côté
l'autre chauffeur est d'avis
grand luxe
ça fait partie du concours quand j'ai
gagné
la journée s'est bien passée
et on va aux
attentes et a bien marqué
ouais un chanteur
[Rires]
je peux me permettre un concert de kanye
west
[Musique]
ham et angie ça me fait quelque chose en
plus qui j'ai une anecdote particulière
et on préfère jouer avec lui au foot ya
main et je l'avais vu je voulais la
guitare quand il était môme away frais
j'ai pris devant revoir fait disposant
il jouait déjà gratter déjà et il avait
un truc et je dis tu vas faire quelque
chose de ta vie que tu vas connaître la
lumière quoi que je ressentais tout ça
tu tu faire bizarre
mais ouais mais se fait pas c'est que
j'ai ressenti tellement en fait j'ai des
espèces de jeu pas si je peux en parler
c'est bizarre et l'avantagé en toute
indépendance et
honnêtement était certes non mais j'ai
pas la connexion avec toi c'est là par
exemple
l'accord je vous vois j'ai
enfants
[Musique]
avec jeux les dents là c'était une
phrase que je
travaille oui vous travaillez avec les
enfants c'est vrai travail et de
santé des trucs 10 boules pas pourquoi
j'ai binic c'est bizarre je peux voler
zoomer par rapport à la femme ivre de
l'amour l'océan peut-être quelque chose
mais à par rapport à vous annoncez votre
visage qui dégage soit vous avez ça le
sud ouest vous dit quelque chose la
famille avec la manne
dans les landes à océan à oui voilà mais
j'arrive pas à
6,6 ce qu à 6 mai
ici il ya quelque chose de six mois
ouais je ne suis qu'un assistant ça fait
6 1 avait quand on sait qui en compte
six ans et ça s'est situé en plein coeur
j'ai un coeur qu'à paris
parce que là j'ai versé en vain parce
que vous avez une belle ouvrage vous
avez quelque chose de joyeux autour de
fringues et huawei et de chance allez
vous avez quelque chose de bien vous
avez quelque chose de lumineux oh là là
je m'émeus je vous promets j'ai cette
lumière qui arrêtent pas de venir c'est
cela m'a tu avais je la mange la voir
[Musique]
la romieu
pour eni
c'est pourquoi anthony saclay à celle
chez chloé exactement clos et qu'il
adore ouais ouais c'est ce que c'est ce
que j'ai compris franchement mais moi
aussi j'adore ce soit la position que je
vais avoir ça va être très très beau je
suis très fier de faire partie de ce
bonheur là je te remercie vraiment un
tueur c'est incroyable de tous bords la
joie de le faire bien sûr c'est parce
qu'ils vont du monde et où la série est
vraiment vraiment merci beaucoup c'est
magique magic ce soit merci je suis trop
contente pour toi c'est un cancer alors
merci à tout le monde génial au dessus
tout cette histoire de vous agresser
vva
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le temps du riz quand tu pleures comme
pluriel quant à tes yeux c'est la vie
mais pas peur rien à vendre et plus fort
que non deux qui a dit que les fleurs ne
pousse que près de chez eux
[Musique]
dire que c'est mieux qu'on se quitte là
mon amour la raison vaudrait mieux ton
seul ace mais mon amour je me souviens
encore quand tu me disais
[Musique]
la famille
ben arfa
labat qu'on a choisi en ce sens qu'il
assure toi allez sûrement qu'elle est
ici remontre là moi je vais le dire tu
es sûr que tu l'as vécu
elle est magnifique quoique je me loupe
est sur scène et de la paire pas sinon
je m'attends pas
j'arrive à le réaliser je pense que nous
aurons pris mais je suivrai l'intention
jamais
ça commence pour tes envies
[Musique]
pourtant
on sent vraiment
non
oh
[Applaudissements]
oui
j'aimerais savoir quelque chose à skis
et le club est dans la salle ce soir
s'il vous plaît chloé est ce qu'il ya eu
comme par hasard si même toit
je
3 j'aimerais que vous venez ici avec
mention assez spartiate est facturé pour
tourner
[Applaudissements]
vous allez voir je me tais je sais c'est
très simple
[Musique]
oui ma chère chloé
[Applaudissements]
en plus à la micro
il aurait ainsi qu à des quelques heures
je suis rappelé sur la scène
avec qui tu es venu quelqu'un de proche
que tu aimes au fond du coeur quelqu'un
de très cher pour toi et
je suis venu avec ma belle soeur mais
sinon c'est mon chéri
chéri
tu sais je le connais au chili
[Musique]
si vous pouvez me faire entrer anthony
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable c'est les demandes en
mariage à la série la nina quoi c'est
ouf c'est
incroyable quel gîte appel devant 10000
car mon cerveau s'est mis en pause et
amel ouest a pensé qu à ce moment là
s'est mis en poche je me suis dit c'est
pas possible je rêve qu'est ce qu'il se
passe là t'as pensé à à rien tu avais
aucune piste non parce que tu sais le
temps que tu montes
sa voix est en poche je me suis laissé
guider oui j'avais l'impression de rêver
incroyantes du coup j'ai jeu j'avais
toutes les émotions le stress la peur et
l'excitation tout mélanger et là ça va
juste être incroyable regardez celle une
très très très lourd
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
niquet
on aime bien comme eh bien mon coeur
tu as toujours été là pour moi ça fait
six ans qu'on est ensemble on a eu un
enfant ensemble millan
et j'étais toujours surpris et là tu
vois j'étais surprend chez nous à
montpellier
veux tu m'épouser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas donné à tous les
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pendant la toussaint
devant j'ai lu
m
on pense plus à me
moi j'ai pu me
messieurs
sow
tout ça c'est mieux
ce n'était pas l'auteur
[Musique]
à menton
c'est pas coller
tout de même important
ce nom
c'est
[Musique]
/
non
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
on y est c'est fait
moi j'ai verser la larme c'est comme ça
c'est
le sénégal j'exige par l'effondrement
mais je compte y intégrant toutes les
émotions ouais mais douch ouais bah j'ai
mis sa tête
c'était trop bien trop bien et puis
angie nous avait fait mal accueillie
comme il fallait pour mettre bientôt à m
aucun chiffre
on aura trois pas vingt trois kenji
série
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était un moment incroyable
j'étais là et je sais pas je voulais
apprendre est vrai et l'embrasser pour
fort que toute chose et la bague et b
étatiques et je peux je leur vol genou à
terre
c'est le moment partie
en amour c'est la deuxième fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que c'est beau l'amour mais si
je n'en voulais vraiment faire ce beau
cadeau alors soyons heureux m éboué
et on vous adore numérique sourire et
surtout merci à vous les amoureux
[Musique]
on a tous les larmes aux yeux on est
hyper ému très très ému de revoir tout
ça moi j'ai les papillons dans le ventre
pour vous en bref c'est magnifique c'est
tout est beau a pas de mots non voilà
alors j'ai aussi quelque chose
d'exceptionnel enfants en tout cas c'est
une surprise pour vous vous attendez
donc un bébé alors si vous voulez avec
johanna encore une fois qui est ta soeur
notre compagnie d'accord on a ici
'l'annonce enfin le résultat du sexe du
bébé est ce que vous voulez le savoir la
maintenant comme ça
vous voulez seront veux et voilà
félicitations au maire s'est fait à moi
je suis prêt
c'est un garçon félicitations
tu te mets un petit frère pour nous elle
se sent petit frère il voulait me faire
il vous l'aviez fait même tu vois je
sais trop bien à
jean quinquis
raveau
merci bravo
c'est cool ce propos c'est génial c'est
un pour 40 à tous les deux merci
beaucoup chloé et anthony d'avoir
partagé ces moments avec nous